[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states and first lady jill
biden accompanied by dr edjah dom
[Music]
so
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you
thank you
gosh
so many friends here it's so nice to see
all of you
and you're getting me so emotional
before i have to speak about cancer
so
anyway
welcome to the white house
and um
you know certain words
have the power
to make time stop
malignant
aggressive
terminal
cancer
like a spell
they still
the air around us
frozen in place
we feel the world we knew slipping away
in the span of a breath
a thousand questions fill our minds
what can i do
how do i tell people
why did this happen
and when the hands of the clock begin to
move once again
we are not the person we once were
but someone
changed
a mother
imagining all of the things she might
not be there to teach her daughters
a husband wondering
how he will juggle chemotherapy
appointments with work
and child care
a son
trying to be strong
for the parents who could
outlive him
it's not just patience
cancer changes everyone it touches
and in some ways
it touches us all
for joe and me
it has stolen our joy
it left us broken in our grief
but through that pain we found purpose
strengthening our fortitude for this
fight to end cancer as we know it
[Applause]
almost almost 30 years ago
four of my friends were diagnosed with
breast cancer in one year
and one of my dear friends winnie lost
her battle
winnie inspired me to take up the cause
of prevention and education
and since then
i've seen the darkness of this disease
financial devastation
confusion over care and far too many
families mourning loved ones
yet
i've also seen hope
in just this last year
i met a woman whose life was saved by
determined nurses who just wouldn't let
her skip her screening
i met a doctor who was inspired to
become a cancer researcher because she
survived her own diagnosis as a child
i've seen people come together
from rival companies or opposite
political parties sharing knowledge and
finding common cause
united by the chance to save lives
a cancer diagnosis today may still leave
us feeling hopeless
but we are not hopeless and we are not
helpless
we are living in a golden age of
research and discovery
we can end this terror and all of us
have a role to play
because this isn't just about hoping
that one person will decipher the
answers alone
it's about listening to patients and
survivors and their families
and easing the burden they face
it's about the individual choices we can
make
to stop this disease before it's too
late
to get screenings to be vigilant with
our health
it's about federal and state governments
the business community and non-profit
organizations
all helping to make those screenings
more available and accessible
it's about bringing the brightest minds
and the fiercest hearts to the table to
learn and to collaborate and to discover
together
yes
cancer has the power
to rewrite our lives
but we have the power too
more than we even know
we can stop it in its tracks
we can comfort and discover and dream
our way past its paralysis
we can come together and rewrite the
story that cancer tells
now as your first lady
i'm deeply proud to be a partner in the
commitments we're making to the cancer
moonshot today
we're ensuring that all of our
government
is ready to get to work
we're going to break down the walls that
hold research back
we're going to bring the best of our
nation together
patients survivors caregivers
researchers doctors and advocates
all of you
so that we can get this done
and i want you to know that i'll be
there working right beside you
so i'm so honored to welcome all of you
here to the white house today
to take this next step
together
we will give americans a reason to hope
we will use this power of this white
house to make your life better
and we will build a future
where the word cancer
forever
loses its power
thank you
now
it's my pleasure to welcome our next
speaker
vice president harris
knows the heartache of cancer but she
also knows how much hope can be found in
our scientific community
she knows it because she saw it
firsthand in her brilliant mother who
dedicated her life to researching breast
cancer
kamala you honor your mom's memory every
single day
but i believe she's especially proud of
you today
please welcome the vice president of the
united states kamala harris
[Applause]
oh
dr jill biden
lady dr jill biden president joe biden
thank you both for your incredible
and long-standing leadership
on an issue of national importance yes
and of personal significance to so many
of us
including me
so as dr biden said uh you know my whole
life i stood witness
as my mother a scientist
worked to under end breast cancer
so my mother taught at public
universities
she worked at a national laboratory
she published groundbreaking research
she was a peer reviewer at the national
institutes of health nih
and collaborated with scientists around
the world
including in france italy and canada
my mother's discoveries
helped save women's lives
and i am so proud
that she brought our nation
and our world closer to the goal
of ending breast cancer as we know it
and today we are closer
than we have ever been
since the turn of the century we have
made significant breakthroughs
we have learned so much
about therapeutics and diagnostics about
public health
and patient care
more people are surviving cancer
more people are enduring cancer
after being diagnosed
than ever before
and the death rate for cancer has fallen
by about 25
over the past 20 years
in a moment our president will lay out
the new goals
ambitious goals
achievable goals
fair nation
to end cancer as we know it
these goals are not abstract
and they will transform
lives
they will improve
lives
and they will save
lives
so i said at the outset that this is an
issue of personal significance
to so many and for me
you see after a lifetime working to end
cancer
cancer ended my mother's life
i will never forget the day that she sat
my sister and me down and told us she
had been diagnosed with colon cancer
it was one of the worst days of my life
and
an experience that sadly
millions and millions of people in our
country have had
my mother was a fighter all five feet of
her
you would have thought she was seven
feet but she was only five
and as i cared for her
during those many months
i watched her courageous fight
but after countless rounds of chemo her
body gave out
she was transferred from the hospital to
hospice
and in fact one of the last questions
she asked the hospice nurse
was are my daughters going to be okay
i miss my mother every day
and i carry her memory with me wherever
i go
when president biden
launched his cancer moonshot five years
ago
i of course thought of my mother
we may not have ended cancer
as we know it
not then but there is still so much work
to do and we are so much closer
the president's cancer moonshot
demonstrates
who he our president is
because as you all know
out of his personal pain
he launched an initiative this
initiative that will help countless
lives the lives of people he may never
meet
this initiative also demonstrates who we
are as a nation
in america we not only dream
we do
we not only see what can be
we see where we can go in a way that
when we reach for the moon
we plant our flag on it
so it is now my honor to introduce
another leader who for many years has
worked tirelessly in the lab and the
clinic
in that spirit from emory university
school of medicine dr ajay and thank you
[Applause]
all these new pandemic rituals taking
off the mask at the podium getting used
to it
thank you vice president harris
it is an honor to be here with you
and to follow the path paved by your
mother
and all the brilliant researchers that
came before and whose shoulders
shoulders we stand upon to the first
lady
thank you for your empathy
and for truly understanding
the pain
and the promise
that is this fight
i am thrilled to be able to be here to
introduce someone that many of us
consider to be
the country's patient advocate in chief
president joe biden
from my vantage point as a neurosurgeon
scientist
constantly thinking of ways to treat
cancer patients to fight cancer
and seeing countless patients every year
and as a board member of the national
brain tumor society
i can confidently say that this is the
most exciting moment in the history of
our field
as a physician as a physician today
when seeing patients with aggressive
cancers like metastatic melanoma or lung
cancer
i know that many more of them will see
durable remissions after treatments with
therapies that harness the body's immune
system to fight their cancer
as a researcher i know the nih has
created grants targeting brilliant young
investigators yes that's that's me
that encourage us uh to take risks
and chart new directions for our work
as an advocate
knowing that there is a president who is
throwing the full weight of the
presidency behind this effort
means that even between big
announcements like this one
all levers of government are being
pulled to create a brighter future for
cancer patients
this is also an exciting moment for me
personally
because
i'm here
as a son of ghanaian immigrants who came
to the united states with nothing
there was a time when i could not
participate in the scientific discussion
in the united states
we have a ways to go before we're
harnessing all of the diverse talents of
our country
people of every race ability gender
gender and orientation
but the progress that we have made means
that we're constantly bringing new ideas
to this challenge
i stand here as a husband to kelly
a father to joseph who's nine and emily
six
to tell you that this is a moment to
believe in a healthier future for all
families
to believe that we can end cancer as we
know it
to believe in science and to believe
in america
standing firm in that belief
it is my honor to introduce the person
charting the course ahead with vision
purpose
and so much hope
the 46th president of the united states
our advocate in chief
joe biden
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
thank you
thank you thank you thank you
i'm joe biden jill biden's husband
i
i want to thank you doctor for that
introduction
but i want to thank you more for all the
effort you put in to
change save all the people's lives
your dedication to
it and as we used to i used to say in
the senate i think it's still said in
the senate excuse the point of personal
privilege
i'd like to see that doctor on the end
there
that's the man
who spent 18 months trying to save our
son's life
doctor i love you
whole family
[Applause]
folks
the doctors optimism and fearlessness
and body is what our cancer moonshot is
all
about and of course i want to thank jill
and kamel and doug
they just shared how personal it is for
them and our families and like so many
of you every one of you have a story
every one of you have a story
my message today is this
we can do this
i promise you we can do this
for all those we lost
for all those we miss
we can end cancer as we know it
i committed to this fight when i was
vice president
it's one of the reasons why quite
frankly i ran for president
let there be no doubt
now that i am present this is a
presidential white house priority period
[Applause]
you know
the bipartisan members of congress and
i've i don't want to start because i'll
leave somebody out
but you know
congress
is here
this is they can tell you one of the
truly bipartisan issues in the united
states congress
i know their votes
but that includes
senator patrick leahy michael bennett
amy klobuchar chris van hollen
sanford bishop
representatives joyce beatty barbara lee
jim mcgovern donald payne debbie
wasserman schultz bonnie
watson-coleman
tom cole brian higgins
i said i'm going to do this
terry's full
terry's soul
and uh it can be truly an american
moment
i'm sure i've left somebody out for
which i apologize
but this can really be an american
moment
that proves to ourselves and quite
frankly to the world
that we can do really big things
you know we made enormous progress in
the past 50 years
since congress passed the president and
president nixon signed into law
the national cancer act and declared war
on cancer
we learned cancer is not a single
disease you should think of that time as
a single disease
there are over 200 as you all know 200
different types of cancer
caused by different genetic mutations in
ourselves
we discover new medicines therapies
early detection prevention measures that
extend lives and save lives
in the first 25 years since the national
cancer act the death rate from cancer
was largely unchanged
then things began to change
the progress over the last 25 years the
death rate has fallen by more than 25
percent
but here's the deal despite the progress
of lives extended in lives saved
cancer is still the number two cause of
death in america
second only to heart disease
in the last two years of covet 19
pandemic
has taken more than the the pandemic has
taken more than 800 000 american lives
but that same period of time
cancers claim 1.2 million american lives
year in and year out
for too many patients and their families
on diagnosed with cancer instead of hope
there's also
bewilderment remember doc you telling
the family
that you had that we had to be able to
ask questions and you were available
because it's a hard road to understand
and traverse
the feeling of being on your own
a
static adrift in a sea of
patience
frustrated that hospitals and doctors
can not only easily share your medical
records
or help find answers when there's
minutes count
having to advocate for even the most
basic
care and attention for your loved one
a flood of information
completely different language
in many cases with no one to help you
decipher it
being within reach of a therapy
a therapy that's too expensive
or your insurance
won't cover it
despite all the progress
there's still a sense of powerlessness
guilt
that maybe you're not doing enough
because you don't know enough
and fear
so when president obama
asked me to launch our cancer moonshot
in our administration our goal was to
bring a new sense of urgency
to make the system of prevention
research
and patient care
to take advantage of the 21st century
science and technology
we began the process
many of you in this room are part of
that we harness the resources of the
federal government to change the culture
increase cooperation
among scientists and break down some of
the silos
i know parenthetically i remember
i wanted to transfer
a particular scan
from
a hospital
in pennsylvania
to a hospital in d.c
and i was told he couldn't do it
wasn't able to do it
could transfers about anything else in
the world
but he couldn't do it
because the hospitals didn't want the
other hospitals to have access to their
because the patients could change their
mind
to all the records
that include everything of making
federally funded cancer research more
accessible to the public
instead of hiding behind a paywall
we launched trials dot cancer
so everyone
can look up cancer clinical trials
across the country and around the world
i travel the country
bringing together leaders of healthcare
technology education business and
technology
i visited most of the major cancer
centers literally in the world
met with heads of state in those
countries
and decided how we could work together
to try to make progress i remember a
particularly good meeting in australia
one of the final pieces of legislation
that president obama signed in law
was the bipartisan
21st century cures act
with the help
of members of congress
particularly i don't know if fred upton
here fred are you here
well fred upton is part of it and dying
to get
in the house
it's streamlined the food and drug
administration fda show that new cancer
treatments
can be evaluated faster
provided seven years of new funding
including research on cancer disparities
trial networks to discover new drugs and
new efforts for childhood cancer
president of the senate as president
senate i presided over the overwhelming
vote
after the election had already taken
place the presidential election
when everything is supposed to come to a
screeching halt
a bipartisan vote
to fund
over six billion dollars
and i watched
my friend and is my friend we disagree a
lot
mitch mcconnell
stand there
and ask unanimous consent to name the
cancer provisions after our son beau
cancer moonshot brought the country and
the world
closer together on this issue
and when we left office sean and i knew
we had to keep it going
so we took a lot of you
we had five nobel laureates and others
who were involved
through the cancer of the biden cancer
initiative we focus on turning the
moonshot into a movement
to create the cancer research and care
system that most people think we already
have
and that they all deserve
but they don't know they don't we don't
have it until they try to
deal with it
and everywhere i'd go
people would share their stories
in grocery stores airports rope lines
while we heard stories of loss and
despair
the stories began to change it's a
little bit
a change of feeling
real hope
but not because of me and jill but
because of all of you in this room and
so many more at home
doctors researchers advocates caregivers
patients survivors
and that's why today i'm proud to
announce
our plan to supercharge the cancer
moonshot
as a central effort of the biden harris
administration
bold
it's ambitious
but it's completely doable
just as we harness the science to
develop cutting-edge covet 19 vaccines
and treatments
will bring a fierce sense of urgency to
the fight against cancer
the goal is to cut the cancer death rate
in half in the next 25 years at least by
50
and to turn more cancer from death
sentences into chronic diseases that
people can live with
to create a more supportive
experience for patients and their
families
and by doing these things and more
and cancer as we know it
and here's what we're fighting
and how we know
what cancer looks like today a disease
where
we often diagnose it too late
we have too few effective ways to
prevent it
the stark inequities based on race
disparity zip code sexual orientation
gender identity and other factors still
persist
and we know too little about why
treatments work in some patients in the
exact same
that same patient with the exact same
diagnosed cancer it doesn't work in that
patient
but we still lack strategies to develop
treatments for for some cancers
where we don't do enough to help
patients and their families navigate
through the process
we don't learn enough from patients
experience
experiences or their data
in fact when we first started this work
one of the first things we did was make
sure that doctors and researchers work
together share information allow
patients to share their data with other
doctors and researchers to help others
but there's so much more to do i
remember we were going through this in
the moonshot
in my saying that i was told level
patients don't want to share their data
they all want to share their data
sometimes y'all don't want to share what
you know
and for each
[Applause]
and for each of the ways we know cancer
today
we know we can change his trajectory
for example to prevent cancer
scientists are exploring
if the new mrna vaccine technology
that brought us safe and effective covet
19 vaccines could also be used to stop
cancer cells when they fail
when they first arrive
get them then
to target the right treatments to the
right patients
we're learning more about how to use
genetics immune response and other
factors
to tell which combinations of treatments
are likely to work
best for a particular individual
to address inequities we can target
prevention detection and treatment
efforts so that all americans whether
urban rural or tribal communities have
equal access to cancer diagnosis
therapeutics clinical trials
there's so much more we can
do as i said at the beginning
this is the presidential priority
i will do my part on funding and using
my authorities as president to break log
jams and speed breakthroughs
i challenge and encourage all of you
all of you to continue to do your part
this will be bipartisan
this will bring the country together
and quite frankly other nations as well
here's some of the actions that i'm
announcing today
first
i formed a new
cancer cabinet which is convened in the
company we will convey in the coming
weeks to include members of the cabinet
who are here today
all the people sitting on the stage here
they'll drive a whole government effort
to unleash every possibility within our
within our power
within their jurisdictions
the white house office of science and
technology policy led by
senior scientists and advisor dr eric
lander sitting on the end
there
will chart the path for the cancer
moonshot for 2022 and beyond
i'm calling on congress to fund my
proposed arpa-h
the advanced research project agency for
health
this will be a new kind of entity within
the national institute of health the nih
with autonomy and authorities to drive
unprecedented progress in biomedicine
it's based on darpa most everybody knows
in this town where darpa is
that's the defense department's advanced
research project agency
that has led to breakthrough
technologies that protect our national
security
from the internet to gps and so much
more
arpa-h will have a singular purpose to
drive breakthroughs to prevent
detect and treat diseases including
cancer alzheimer's and diabetes
and other diseases
and i think there's strong bipartisan
support for this
but it costs money
and it's the best these are the best
dollars we could spend
so we got to get it done we got to get
it done now not wait any longer
i'm also calling on the scientific and
medical communities
to bring the boldest thinking to this
fight
i'm calling on the private sector to
develop and test new treatments make
drugs more affordable
and share more
more data and knowledge that can inform
the public and benefit every company's
research
and i'm respectfully calling on people
living with cancer and caregivers and
families to keep sharing their
experience and pushing for progress
you'll have a voice and a seat at the
table i promise you
but here's the one thing we can all do
america has missed more than 909 million
cancer screenings in the last two years
because of cope 9 million
we have to get cancer screenings back on
track
and make sure they're accessible
to all americans
so today i'm announcing a call to action
for cancer screening and early detection
if you're supposed to get a cancer
screening during the pandemic
call your primary care doctor today
if you're that doctor
talk to your patients
get a screening schedule
whether it's in the office at home or
through telehealth visit
because the affordable care act now
will cover most private insurance plans
as well as medicare medicaid to cover
the recommended preventive care
screening free of charge
i'm calling on companies
health care providers non-profits and
others to step up including developing
mobile units and pop-up clinics
to reach people where they live
and if you're putting off screening
because you're afraid of what you'll
find they'll find
let me say this and so many people are
put it off
last november
i got a colon cancer screening
i'm glad i did
trust me
i know cancer is scary
going to the doctors can be scary
but screening is how you catch it early
before it's too late the earlier you get
it the better shot you have
let me close with this
there's a quote
that
when i made one of these speeches years
ago five six years ago attributed was
attributed to yo yo ma
i later was informed and attributed to
vince lombardi
but whoever the hell gives a quote
it makes sense here's the quote
practice
makes
permanent
only perfect practice makes
perfect my challenge to everyone
involved in this fight against cancer
take a hard look at your practice
ask yourself if you're practicing
perfectly
or am i practicing to make the old way
permanent
all practices have created data silos
minimize the role of patients foster the
wrong kind of competition
instead of the right kind of
collaboration
i know we can get this right
i'm positive we can
by not losing sight of the ultimate goal
the patient's health
and by not losing sight of something
else i also believe
america
is a single place on earth single
country that can be defined as i told xi
jinping by one word
possibilities
possibilities
when we work together in america
there is nothing
nothing beyond our capacity nothing
so let's show the world what's possible
let's show the world
that we're committed
let's show that we can do big things
that the united states of america
when we work together there's nothing
beyond our grasp i mean nothing beyond
our grasp
and i know of nothing as i think my
colleagues would say that's more
bipartisan
and take on this fight
and fundamentally change cancer as we
know it
it's a mission that can truly
unify the nation
it shows us at our best working together
and rather than working against one
another
for every patient asking for one more
day
i remember i've met i met with over 3000
researchers in the various organizations
and they're good they're they're they're
devoting their whole lives to try to
save me
and they work really long hours
but they're not practitioners
they've not had
that patient come up and say doc
can you give me just two more weeks
so i can see my daughter married
doc
all i need can you do anything and give
me just
six more months
to see the baby born
that's all i'm asking for doc
there's a sense of overwhelming urgency
overwhelming urgency
if you're a patient or a family member
of a patient
every patient
asking just for one more day they're not
asking to cure me
one more day
one more week
can i get another year to be able to do
boom
for survivors and caregivers who carry
the physical and mental scars
of treatments in recovery
and for those who
have lost
and for the ones we can still save
let's end cancer as we know it
i refuse to believe
i refuse to believe
this is beyond our capacity
i refuse to believe it
you know when i put together the cancer
moonshot
i was vice president the president gave
me authority to task anyone in the
administration
when i found out i had the department of
energy and ernie moniz
when they found out i had
i had
nasa
and a lot of other agencies looked at me
like what's the matter with you
i said guess what
nasa knows more about radiation than all
of you
seriously
and ernie moniz we're at a place we get
a billion billion calculations per
second
and goes on
skills people never thought would impact
on this
can do it
so my plea to you scientists is
share data as best you can
my plea to my members in congress is
let's fund this particular program
and focus on it till we beat it
because the american people
keep the hope alive
there is hope
there is hope
and i'm confident
absolutely confident
if we make all our effort to deal with
it
we can make fundamental changes in
people's lives
and change the families
in this country
in a much better position they are today
with regard to cancer
thank you all for being here i
appreciate it
[Applause]
[Applause]
don't spread the faith guys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]